I've got to switch gears for a little
bit here
because I've got to defend my friend
Matt Walsh Matt has been getting in big
trouble with the Media Matters and all
of the libs who are calling Matt a
racist they call us all racists because
Matt pointed out that mermaids are not
black
because Matt pointed out that mermaids
are white this is a scientific fact he
actually says that mermaids are
translucent
like all those sorts of creepy little
fish at the bottom of the sea
uh and this has become a big National
debate that then has gone I I think into
the realm of this absurd where one
prominent lib on social media
said that the debate is is stupid and
lad is obviously a racist because
they're ignoring the fact that mermaids
don't even exist and I thought what are
you talking about mermaids don't exist
are you you're telling me it's 20 22. in
2022 there are still people who are
seriously arguing that mermaids do not
exist even after Christopher Columbus
saw several of them with his own eyes in
1493. even after John Cook famous sailor
John Cook
saw a mermaid
also back in the 17th century are you
kidding me
doesn't make sense
there there are many eyewitness accounts
of mermaids now I'm not saying
that mermaids definitely exist okay I'm
just saying there are many eyewitness
accounts of mermaids spanning at least
several centuries and then going Way Way
Back Into folklore I guess the point I
want to make is amid all of our modern
hubris about what all those stupid crazy
old people thought all these fantastic
delusional things I just want to point
out that for instance there is much more
scientific evidence that mermaids exist
than that the covid vaccines present
infection transmission
for sure you've got all of the the
modern
really fancy white lab coat wearing
stethoscope having modern scientists who
said that the covid vaccines will
prevent infection and transmission of
the virus and all I'm pointing out is
many more people have seen mermaids than
have seen the covid vaccine prevent
infection and transmission of the virus
there are all sorts of modern scientific
things
that are much less plausible
than mermaids
the idea that global warming is going to
kill us all in 10 years and that was a
few years ago that people were
predicting that the idea that global
cooling was going to kill us all within
a couple of decades the idea that the
overpopulation was going to cause Mass
worldwide famines those predictions were
made by Major environmentalist groups in
1970 none of that happened
actually the world population doubled
malnutrition hit an all-time low
people became fatter than ever
much more evidence of mermaids than of
overpopulation
there's a kind there's just a modern
hubris that we have
we look in the past we say oh my gosh
those dumb old people in the I don't
know the Renaissance or the Middle Ages
or ancient times they believe the
craziest things they're big dumb idiots
because they didn't even have iPhones
like I do I'm so smart
We Believe way crazier things than they
did there are way crazier things to
believe in than mermaids okay I'll give
you an example of one this guy Jack
turban who I've I've seen him before
he's some lib blue check he's got all
sorts of weird like gay flags and things
in his uh Twitter bio and and he's got
his his degree MD says Jack turban MD
and he is a radical transgender activist
uh so this is what he tweets at he says
four years at Harvard five years at Yale
three more years at Harvard two years at
Stanford but Karen zero five two six
seven eight nine has some thoughts about
sex chromosomes and what he's saying
there at the end is you idiot
conservatives you seem to think that men
and women are different you don't
believe in transgenderism but I went to
Harvard you see and because I went to
Harvard I know that boys are secretly
girls or whatever
that's his argument
reminds me of Socrates Socrates famously
when arguing with an idiot he says look
neither me nor this idiot know anything
about what is really good and beautiful
but I have a little bit of an advantage
over this guy
because this guy doesn't know anything
and he thinks he knows something and I
don't know anything and I know that I
don't know anything
and it is amazing but
I have never seen somebody
with their academic degree listed in
their Twitter name You Know Jack turbin
MD or so and so PhD I've never seen
someone who lists an academic degree in
their name
who seems intelligent or wise
find me the counter example I don't mean
it just to call my opponents idiots
right it's really not I'm just saying if
you compare
the kinds of people who list their
academic degrees and who boast about
things like I went to Harvard for this
many years and I went to Stanford and
that's why I'm so much smarter than
everybody else every time I see people
like that they seem way dumber and they
believe way crazier stuff than the
people who have any humility whatsoever
but of course this is the case this is
always the case this is not some new
phenomenon
the people who think of themselves as
super duper smart usually look like
fools and are given to Pride and hubris
and end up believing insane things and
the people who recognize that actually
we don't really know very much of
anything at all they tend to be much
wiser
and this is one of the one of the
Delights of our fallen world one of the
consolations of it is the people who
consider themselves really really smart
and wise
pretty much always look like big dumb
idiots okay
this guy Jack turbine believes that boys
are secretly girls and girls are
secretly boys and advocates
giving them all sorts of drugs and
cross-sex hormones and and bodily
genital mutilations so that little boys
look more like little girls and vice
versa and it's ghastly and it's horrible
but if you can just not think about the
suffering and pain caused by this for a
second you just think of it in a more
abstracted way it's absolutely freaking
hilarious that this dude has spent how
long he's spent how many years in the
ivy league five at Harvard four at
Harvard five at Yale three more at
Harvard something like that it's kind of
hard to see here four years at Harvard
yeah there we go nine twelve oh then
another two at Harvard so and then and
then you've got Stanford on top of that
so this guy's been in throughout the ivy
league and all the top schools forever
and he thinks that boys can secretly be
girls
it's amazing
you you out there listening very likely
did not spend all these many years A
Dozen Years in the ivy league and yet
you know that boys are not girls you are
much smarter than this man you have much
more wisdom
so it's a real lesson a little humility
goes a long way speaking of LGBT
one of the most hilarious episodes that
I've ever seen come out of sports just
came out of UMass so UMass the football
team is supposed to play Liberty
University and to own
the the libs to own the Liberties really
to own the Christian conservatives UMass
has declared that their football team is
super duper gay
it says please stand by for a special
announcement
type music going on Pride day
over the football player dancing around
in a rainbow looking Club
Massachusetts versus Liberty
October 8th
3 30 yeah and he's pointing he's like
this is pride day baby
now I thought Pride day was
it wasn't Pro Pride was originally a day
then it was a week now then it was a
month but that was back in June but now
it's September and we're hearing the
pride day is going to be in October it's
just Pride all the time because LGBT is
is the kind of public religion and
public Liturgy of of the libs and so
they're forcing that on everybody else
but the UMass football team is now
they're so triggered by anyone who's
Christian or conservative like Liberty U
that in order to own the Christian
conservatives they're saying yeah yeah
you're gonna well guess what we're super
gay yeah we're not we're not even just
gay we're trans that's right yeah look
at us oh I bet you guys are so triggered
we're yeah us the UMass football team
we're actually little girls yeah that's
right yeah aren't you totally owned no
not not really at all
not really at all you are in in a vain
attempt to own liberty and the Christian
conservatives you're making yourself
look
at the very least frivolous and foolish
I'm so glad you like that clip now hold
up you gotta ring that Bell subscribe
get all the notifications we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]